crossing Australia's desert in a
solar-powered car used to be a mere pipe
dream but this weekend almost 40 slick
Sun guzzling machines started a 3,000
kilometer journey from Darwin to
Adelaide using just the sun's rays for
powers cars will reach speeds of over
100 kilometres an hour
world Solar Challenge defending
champions new on solar are once again
among the favorites this year all the
cars look completely different all we
know is we've got a good car we got it
running perfectly in the last couple of
days and we're really confident we're
gonna do everything it takes to win
teams completed a time trial to
determine the starting order with the
frontrunners grabbing a vital advantage
that could make all the difference
overtaking takes a lot of energy that we
would otherwise not want to use so we
feel very happy to be in third but we
don't have to overtake that many cars
leaving Darwin teams are expected to
finish the race within a week that the
record is just under 30 hours
competitors are hoping their desert
hopping exploits can one day see
solar-powered cars take over the roads
full time